in being and nothingness written in 1943
the French existentialist philosopher
jean-paul sartre identified a problem
which he believed plagued Modern Life
m'avez fois literally bad faith bad
faith occurs when we lie to ourselves in
order to spare ourselves short-term pain
but thereby suffer from long-term
psychological impoverishment we force
ourselves to believe something which
were not really convinced by because
it's easier in particular subtle
believed that what we constantly lie to
ourselves about is that we don't have
other options we always do but find it
curiously more reassuring to say we
don't
it lets us off the hook bad faith often
happens around work Sartre describes a
waiter who tells himself that he's just
a waiter
it's his lot in life his destiny he
tells himself he had no choice that he
has to keep on at it because he needs
the money but it's not true insist
Sartre
we are all free there are scary almost
sickening moments of what sort of calls
negative ecstasy which might come late
at night when we realize that we are in
fact far more free than we ever say we
are that we could throw in the job go
and live in the woods or reinvent
ourselves it can be harrowing because we
have to acknowledge that we may be
wasting our lives and that in the end
this is our own fault however much at
other times were tempted to blame
circumstances or other people but we
then typically suppress this insight the
next day we force ourselves to believe
in what we're doing the price is that we
close off the opportunities for changing
and improving our lives we forget Souths
says that being precedes essence that is
who we are
can't be pinned down to one particular
job or relationship our being is much
bigger it embraces in South's words all
the things we are at present not but
could possibly become in bad faith we
keep those possibilities out of our
minds we tell ourselves that the way we
are at the moment is the only way we can
be
so bad faith closes down on the options
of freedom startled detected bad faith
as a feature of many unhappy
relationships
he describes its origins in early dates
when a couple secretly realized that
they're not at all compatible but then
forced themselves to believe that they
can be happy together in South sample a
woman wants to be loved for her mind and
can't bear to pay attention to her own
dark suspicions that her partner is in
fact more interested in her body
meanwhile the man realizes that the
woman isn't interested in him sexually
but keeps telling himself that really
she must be they both lie to themselves
and that's why they end up together and
unhappy bad faith will lead them to
throw the blame on each other saying
it's the others coldness or lack of
sophistication that's the problem when
really it's their own doing sucker
didn't see bad faith as a surprising or
unusual problem it's a natural outcome
of how our minds work he didn't want us
to feel bad he just wanted to remind us
to be as free as we really are
you